So for the first thing we are going to do.
is
Get the characteristic polynomial.
And to do that we will need the determinant.
function
whose argument
is the identity Matrix multiplied?
By Lambda, let me write it down. So we will
have
times are in linear algebra. I is the identity
Matrix.
And step two will be the characteristic polynomial.
So we have if you remember we said that the identity Matrix.
Since the Matrix a is a 2 by 2
the identity Matrix will be a 2 by 2.
Yes, if we multiply the scalar.
With the identity Matrix, what do we get? So we have
the scale of Lambda?
Whose value is to be determined? That's why this function
called determinant.
We are trying to determine the the undetermined
which and that undetermine is that Lambda.
a Greek letter
So what we will do is then we will take this identity Matrix.
multiplied by Lambda
2 well, we know what we see what happens in Jupiter
notebook when you multiply the scalar.
product on the what the identity Matrix
just for clarity. I'm going to use the
time symbol
so multiply that Skiller and these will be replaced.
So we can put this scalar here next to
it.
And this will give us a new Matrix.
But all the ones have now become.
Lambda
this
we will then put inside the determinate function.